Brady asked me about hafnium
and it turns out it's far more exciting
than I thought it burns really well
it has a great back story it has strange
links to mobile phones and to nuclear
reactors and it's very expensive what
more could Brady want
hafnium is element
72 on the periodic table it's on the
same group as titanium and zirconium
and hefnim is underneath that turns out
to be a really important fact in its
Discovery
2023 is a really important year for
hafnium because it was discovered at
least that the paper announcing its
Discovery was published on the 20th of
January
1923 so it's just over 100 years old it
wasn't isolated immediately but that's
when its existence was proved that paper
gave rise to one of the biggest rows in
science at the beginning of the 20th
century I inquired about hafnim to our
friend Tony lippman he said it's a
really hot metal everyone wants some but
we on periodic table of videos are his
friends so he'd find some for us and it
arrived by post
a few days ago two samples
one a nice packet with two pieces of
very shiny metal and the other one with
a much larger lump
but which had interesting features
almost crystallites in it Neil was very
excited but it turns out that it's
really tough
Neil tried to straighten it with his
hands he was defeated
so he needed to use a hammer
I'd never seen metallic caffeine
and I didn't know much about it and I
read that it didn't dissolve in acids
easily but I thought there's a challenge
for Neil
so Neil got out his fuming nitric acid
which he believes dissolves everything
[Music]
but hafnim was completely Untouched by
it
these nitric acid has met its match and
we tried another acid concentrated
hydrochloric acid
still nothing but Neil would not be
defeated so he brought out the aqua
regia which dissolves gold aqua regia is
a mixture of HCL hydrochloric acid and
concentrated nitric acid and they react
together to make a much more corrosive
solution and hafnium much to Neil's
pleasure began to react
that was a bit slow
and Neil said even gold reacts faster
with aqua regia and being Neil he
produced a small piece of gold and we
ran them in competition
the gold was a bit slow getting started
but by the time that Neil and Brady were
packing up
it had largely dissolved and the hafnium
was still there sometime later this is
the golden Avenue
is
foreign
so let me explain about its Discovery
even Mendeleev thought that there should
be another element on the periodic table
where hapnium is but everything was
confused by the discovery of the rare
Earths there was some discussion would
happen be the last of the rare Earths or
would it be the first of the next row of
transition metals the transition metals
are the metals that go across the
periodic table from left to right and so
the French chemist orbang the one who
discovered luticium
thought that he would look among the
rare Earths and before the first world
war he thought he discovered elements 72
which he gave the name celtium or it may
be calcium
from like the English word Celtic
c-e-l-t ium then it turned out that it
made a mistake so when he and the
colleague published again after the
first world war in 1922
people didn't really want to believe him
he was The Boy Who Cried Wolf precisely
and then in 1923 a Hungarian chemist
working in Denmark called the hevicy
together with the Dutch colleague Costa
published the paper in the journal
Nature which described their discovery
of element 72 and the paper is quite
interesting
because first of all the editor writes
that he takes no responsibility for the
content of the paper whether it's right
or wrong and secondly it was published
very quickly and is very short like most
of these papers announcing discoveries
of new elements and because they were
working in Denmark in Copenhagen they've
decided to call it hafnium from the
Latin word or what they believed was the
Latin name of Copenhagen which is half
Neil
I don't know it's a Latin name that is
like Hefner where did celtium come from
why did the other guy want Celtic it's
because the original had inhabitants of
France
were Celts
in English there were Celts I suspect in
French they would be called celt they
were both rather patriotic names and the
French were really against the paper
from Denmark because they have seen who
was the lead author had fought on the
Austrian side in the first world war and
it was only five years after the end of
the war so it was nerves were a bit Raw
oh
hafnim was supported by Niels Bohr the
very famous physicist and celtium was
supported by Ernest Rutherford and so
they were both trying behind the scenes
to bend the ear of the editor of nature
whose reputed to have allowed ball to
read the proofs of the French papers
before they were published I think
nowadays after 100 years we can say it
was all a bit dodgy eventually hafnium
triumphed I think it's a better name
because celtium is really a bit like
cerium and probably would confuse
generations of students now the real
reason that they were successful is the
pair in Denmark
realized that hafnim was in the
zirconium group
so they were looking in zirconium
minerals
you can see here it's a couple of nice
samples of zirconium metal also from
Anthony and hafnim is found as an
impurity in um zirconium when you
isolate it from the minerals the French
team because they thought it was a rare
earth we're looking at the minerals from
Italy and places like that where there
are tiny traces of hafnium but it's
enormously more difficult to find it so
all the signals in their Spectrum were
very weak so there's quite a good moral
for you if you're going to look for an
element look at the periodic table first
so you know where to look now we come to
the most exciting part that Neil
discovered Neil took his file and
started making finely divided filings of
hafnium Neil as you know is not a small
guy and he found it really quite hard to
abrade much of it of the piece of Hefner
they didn't trust my shaking hands to
hold it so Connor a rather technician
came to hold the paper and when Neil
sprinkled the hafnium dust into the
Bunsen flame it burned to make
presumably the oxide
it was really quite artistic
wow that's that's impressive
there's a lot going on there Brady who
had been a little bored up till this
point started getting really excited
and the big smile spread upon Neil's
face and this demonstrates the other
thing I read which that's high
temperature happening Burns but only
when it's very finally divided Brady
who thinks about the periodic table
probably more than the rest of us
pointed out that he wasn't very
surprised that tafnian burnt well
because zirconium Burns quite nicely as
well if you watch as zirconium video you
will see similar Flames when we draw
Sparks when we drop in the zirconium my
personal feeling is that hafnim was a
little bit better
because it's denser and therefore it
falls better into the flame because the
flame you imagine is very turbulent with
the burning and so it's easy for the
particles to be knocked out it's up to
you to judge this brings us to
why we have hafnium at all
because
until very recently it hasn't had many
uses it has a very high melting point
apparently it was used in the nozzles
for the Rocket motors on the lunar
lander on the Apollo mission two
[Applause]
unfortunately it also has a disadvantage
that it absorbs neutrons
and therefore it is a very bad impurity
to have in nuclear reactors this matters
because zirconium
is used for cladding the fuel rods in a
nuclear reactor
so the hafnium that we have is a
byproduct of the zirconium industry for
the nuclear power plants
so without nuclear power plants we
probably wouldn't have much production
of hafanim at all so basically when
they're producing the pure zirconium
they have to get all the hafney amount
yes but now
it is suddenly become really important
material
because
in electronics
as you probably know
transistors which are at the heart of
whatever computer or phone that you're
watching this on the transistors get
smaller and smaller and smaller and as
they get smaller you need more
specialized materials to act as
insulators and hafnium oxides turn out
to be very good for making computer
chips
really high Purity and this is now where
most of the hafnium from the nuclear
industry is going and there's another
really exciting development if you have
a smartphone and most people do now you
probably don't realize that inside the
screen that's just under the glass there
is an electrically conducting layer
which is transparent
so that you can see the display
and at the moment most phones use indium
but indium is getting scarce
and it is now being realized that
perhaps it could be replaced by hafnium
or compound of hefnim I'm not sure if
I've ever shown you a patent
but this is a recent one from the Korean
company Samsung patents and legal
documents they're usually very boring to
read but you can see from the title this
talks about transparent screens and at
the back of the patent they're the
claims where they claim what their new
invention can do and you can see there's
a whole list of claims some of which
involve screens so it may well be that
your future phones will have hafnium in
them
you can support our videos and have your
name appear on our Periodic Table of
patrons there's a link to our patreon in
the video description where you can find
out more and last time I checked no
one's put their name on hafnium yet you
could be the first
and there's an equilibrium someone
coming off an equal number are going
back on to the surface so if you just
have the gold in there it appears to be
unaffected if you were on an atomic
scale you'd see atoms coming off and
others going back